[Music]
your life slips away from you you know
changing your phone number and your
email becomes normal
[Music]
taking out a restraining order normal
relocating to another city normal but
you still see your stalker everywhere
rationally I know this is my imagination
but I'm alone in a strange city and I
never feel safe or there's some more
forms you need to fill out it's just
routine
I finished my homework so your Valentini
please follow me look I don't have a lot
of time I should be back at work so what
am i doing in here
take off your clothes down to your
underwear I'm not sure what's happening
here the door's locked
it would be better for everyone
especially yourself if you just do as I
ask there's been some kind of mistake
by signing this you've consented the
voluntary commitment I am being held
here against my will do you know how
many calls the cops get like that every
week those are from crazy people he's
followed me all the way here from Boston
my stalker is here we did a thorough
background check you should be
protecting me mum no woman believes me
I'm getting you out there's nothing we
can do unless you have proof that a
crimes been committed
I must be insane saying my mom didn't
pick up last night
hello it must be insane what happened to
her my dead body was discovered he's
here or maybe it's all in my head
[Music]
you